.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
An dieser Idee ist für mich nichts
revolutionär, innovativ oder neu.
Für mich ist das in Bezug
auf dieses Seeufer deplatziert.
(Mann) Ich hatte
immer ein Boot auf dem See.
Ich kenne diese Ecke seit 14 Jahren.
Ich glaube, dass wir alle einsehen,
dass bei den Isleten
irgendwas gemacht werden muss.
Solche Retortenresorts
sind out of der Zeit,
in der wir heute leben.
Auch auf den Kanton Uri bezogen:
Was sind denn die Urner Werte?
Das sind sie für mich nicht.
Eveline Lüönd,
Präsidentin der Grünen Uri.
Hier geboren. Hier aufgewachsen.
Seit 44 Jahren hier zu Hause.
Die Urner Berglerin kämpft gegen den
ägyptischen Milliardär Samih Sawiris.
Er, der im Kanton Uri
ein nächstes Projekt plant:
eine Marina mit Hotel und Jachthafen
am Vierwaldstättersee.
Er sagt ja nicht,
er habe die Isleten gekauft
und möchte etwas machen,
das für alle gut ist.
Er sagt, die Quadratmeter,
die er gekauft hat,
müssten eine Rendite geben,
sonst sei es nicht interessant.
Das hat bestimmte Prinzipien,
und die sind wirtschaftlich.
Separee.
So.
April 2022.
Eveline Lüönd
organisiert den Widerstand.
Grüezi miteinander. Guten Abend.
Das Ziel des heutigen Abends ist ...
Es geht um die Informations-
veranstaltung von morgen.
Sie sagen,
der Ort sei ein Schandfleck,
da müsse man was machen.
Wir finden, schon dort könnte man
eine andere Geschichte erzählen.
Es kann auch ein schöner Ort sein,
der noch ein bisschen was braucht.
Aber keine völlige Umkrempelung
und Überbauung.
Die Idee einer Marina
von Samih Sawiris
schlägt im Urkanton mit
37'000 Einwohnerinnen und Einwohnern
hohe Wellen.
10'000 Personen haben eine Petition
der Grünen Uri
und eines Gegenkomitees
gegen das Projekt am Urnersee
unterschrieben.
Zu gross, zu protzig, zu luxuriös -
so die Befürchtungen.
Wie kann man ein Stück des Urnersees
wegnehmen,
das ein Investor dann verbauen kann,
anstatt etwas für die Einheimischen
zu machen?
Man darf sich nichts vormachen:
In Bauen werden die Grundstückpreise
durch die Decke gehen.
In Andermatt kann man sich
keine Wohnung mehr leisten.
Wenn einer in dem Resort arbeitet,
der eh schlecht verdient ...
Ich habe von einem Freund gehört,
dass seine Frau 19.50 Fr. verdient.
Das wird ...
- Das ist ein bisschen ...
... eine Illusion, nur mit den
Arbeitsplätzen zu argumentieren.
Meine Frau hat im Chedi gearbeitet.
Dort haben - wenn überhaupt -
knapp 10 % Urner gearbeitet.
Das ist ein Scheinargument.
- Von 250 Mitarbeitern.
Aufgrund meines Hintergrunds
in Andermatt ...
Politisch müsste ich dafür sein.
Politisch bin ich rechts.
Aber ich kann das nicht
unterschreiben, ganz ehrlich.
Wie es hier läuft und in Andermatt
gegangen ist - irgendwann ist genug.
Samih Sawiris,
ein Altbekannter in Uri:
Der Ägypter trat hier
schon einmal als Retter auf,
kaufte grosse Flächen von Andermatt
und baute das Bergdorf
zu einer Luxusferiendestination um.
(Sawiris) Das Projekt sind
ein Golfplatz und einige Hotels.
Und auch eine Verbindung
zum jetzigen Dorf,
damit das alles als Einheit wirkt.
Ich muss immer wieder warnen:
Das ist kein fertiger Plan.
Das wurde viel zu schnell,
viel zu oberflächlich gemacht.
Es dient lediglich zur Darstellung
der Grundidee
unseres Gesamtprojekts.
Immer wieder ein neues Projekt
anzufangen, ist ein Hobby von mir.
Ein Hobby,
ob dem sich die Marina-Widerständler
mässig begeistern können.
Eveline Lüönd schwört die Gruppe ein,
ermuntert sie, ihre Bedenken
an der morgigen Infoveranstaltung
von Samih Sawiris kundzutun.
Ich finde es einfach wichtig,
dass man sich meldet.
Vielleicht meldet sich jemand,
aber 20 sagen vielleicht: "Mhm."
Das gibt ein Bild der Stimmung.
Wenn es einfach ruhig ist ...
Wenn ich referiere und es ist ruhig,
denke ich, das sei super
und ihr fändet das gut.
Eveline Lüönd
darf nicht zur Infoveranstaltung.
Zutritt erhalten nur
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Gemeinden,
auf deren Gebiet
die Marina gebaut werden soll.
Parteikollegin Martina Wüthrich
wird ihre Präsidentin
über die ägyptischen Bauvorstellungen
informieren.
Ich kann über dich erfahren,
wie die Stimmung so war.
Ich besuche Eveline Lüönd
in Schattdorf,
wo sie heute
mit ihrem Lebenspartner wohnt.
Vor 30 Jahren
ging ich hier mit ihr zur Schule.
Im Gegensatz zu mir ist sie
dem Kanton Uri immer treu geblieben,
arbeitet hier in der kantonalen
Gesundheitsförderung.
Ich bin einfach sehr gerne hier.
Ich fühle mich sehr zu Hause,
sehr wohl.
Verbunden mit dieser Landschaft.
Und auch mit den Leuten.
Ja.
Ich geniesse es extrem,
am Morgen hier runterzufahren.
Eigentlich egal,
zu welcher Tageszeit.
Ich sehe mir die Berge in den
verschiedenen Jahreszeiten an ...
Ja, es ist einfach ein schöner Ort.
Lüönd will die Augen vor
Herausforderungen in ihrem Kanton
nicht verschliessen.
Seit drei Jahren setzt sie sich
als Präsidentin der Grünen Uri
für mehr Nachhaltigkeit,
mehr Umweltschutz ein.
Mit dem Marina-Projekt
des Milliardärs Sawiris
kann sie nichts anfangen.
Es geht nicht nur darum,
ob einem das gefällt.
Je nachdem, was dort passiert
und in welcher Dimension ...
... bringt das einfach eine Verände-
rung für viele Urnerinnen und Urner
in ihrem täglichen Leben:
bei der Arbeit, beim Einkaufen ...
Das kann starke Einflüsse haben.
Die Isleten am Urner Seebecken -
Eingangstor ins Isenthal,
Verbindung zwischen den Gemeinden
Seedorf und Bauen.
Samih Sawiris kauft im Dezember 2021
das Gelände
einer ehemaligen Sprengstofffirma.
Eine Risikoinvestition.
Um das Gebiet
touristisch nutzen zu können,
braucht es eine Richt-
und Zonenplanänderung.
Sawiris ist auf
die Zustimmung des Volkes angewiesen.
Bekommt er die nicht, platzt
der Traum einer Marina am Urnersee.
April 2022.
Der Investor lädt die Bevölkerung
der beiden betroffenen Gemeinden
in die Rollhockeyhalle von Seedorf,
will sie von seiner Idee überzeugen.
Was hat der Grossinvestor
vor an der Isleten?
Letzte Besprechungen
in der Club-Beiz.
Martina, welche Erwartungen
hast du nach dem gestrigen Abend?
Wie fühlt es sich an,
heute hier zu sein?
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Erstens mal darauf,
wie die Bevölkerung reagiert.
Aber auch darauf, was erzählt wird.
Auftritt Samih Sawiris.
Gehen wir rauf?
Ohne Krawatte und in Turnschuhen
tritt er auf die Bühne,
wirkt gewohnt und betont volksnah.
Willst du auch Wasser?
- Nein.
Die Medien werden zur Seite gebeten.
Wir dürfen nur von der Tribüne aus
filmen.
Flankiert ist der Ägypter
von hochrangigen Kantonspolitikern:
Regierungsrat Daniel Furrer
und der ehemalige Ständerat
Isidor Baumann rechts,
die zuständigen Gemeindepräsidenten
Toni Stadelmann und Erich Infanger
links.
Bis auf einen Parteilosen
alle CVP-Die Mitte.
Die Präsidentin der Grünen
hat bei diesem Anlass keinen Platz.
Eveline Lüönd erfährt nicht direkt
von Samih Sawiris,
was er am Urnersee bauen will.
Eine Anfrage,
ob sie teilnehmen dürfe,
haben die Verantwortlichen
mit Nein beantwortet.
Ich bedauere es,
dass ich die Informationen
nicht aus erster Hand erhalte.
Ich kriege es natürlich mit.
Ich habe Leute,
die mich informieren.
Es gibt einem auch das Gefühl,
aktiv ausgeschlossen zu werden.
Ganz offen:
Das überrascht mich nicht.
Ich habe das erwartet.
Ich dachte nicht,
dass man eine Kritikerin
mit offenen Armen empfängt.
Ich habe auch damit gerechnet,
dass man unter sich bleiben will.
Herr Sawiris, wie stiessen Sie
ausgerechnet auf das Gebiet Isleten?
Und was fasziniert Sie
an ein paar Parzellen
in einer Gewerbe-
und Industriebrache,
auf der einige wenige alte
und v.a. baufällige Gebäude stehen?
Darf ich Sie bitten?
Ich kenne diese Ecke ...
... seit 14 Jahren.
Aber man hat mir gesagt:
"Sag kein Wort darüber,
mach erst mal Andermatt,
sonst nimmt dich niemand ernst."
Ich habe sehr lange geschwiegen
und mich gar nicht darum gekümmert.
Ich habe es aber nie vergessen.
Ich hatte
immer ein Boot auf dem See.
Ich habe es immer wieder gesehen.
Vom Wasser aus sieht es nicht
so schlimm aus, wie es drinnen ist.
Samih Sawiris träumt davon,
auf dem Areal
der ehemaligen Sprengstofffabrik
ein Hotel mit 50 Zimmern
und 100 Wohnungen zu bauen.
Der Hafen soll nach innen
in die Marina verlegt werden.
* Düstere Musik *
Hört man mich?
Ich wollte zwei Bemerkungen dazu
machen:
Ich glaube,
das sieht man in den Skizzen nicht.
Diese kleine Insel in der Mitte
ist ein Kinderspielplatz.
Das ist mir sehr wichtig.
Und die Segelschule
ist auch sehr wichtig für mich.
Kinder müssen ziemlich früh
mit Segeln anfangen,
damit sie später auch den America's
Cup in der Schweiz behalten können.
Das ist schon lange her.
Das sind zwei wichtige Bemerkungen
für mich.
Und die dritte:
Ich habe ein bisschen gezählt.
Es hat hier zu viele Häuser.
Das sind viel mehr als die
Wohnungen, die wir bauen wollen.
Die Amerikaner, die uns da halfen,
haben tüchtig reingehauen.
Im Endeffekt wird es etwas kleiner.
Das sind die Bemerkungen. Danke.
* Applaus *
Ich hätte gerne
etwas mehr Informationen
zur Isentalerbach-Renaturierung,
damit Herr Sawiris
beim Bau Geld sparen kann.
Wie soll das aussehen?
Sie können
doch nicht wirklich erwarten,
dass in diesem Stadium
bereits so intensive ...
... und detaillierte Studien
gemacht werden.
Was wollen wir im Kanton Uri?
Wollen wir alles zubauen,
um der Rendite willen,
oder wollen wir auch Platz schaffen,
um ihn für uns zu nutzen?
Wenn der Kanton und die Gemeinden
wirklich sagen,
sie wollten das lieber selber machen
und bereit sind,
das und jenes so zu gestalten ...
... bin ich immer dafür zu gewinnen.
Es geht mir nicht darum,
den grossen Profit zu machen.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr würdet das Land
bezahlen und alles selber machen ...
... stellt sich nur die Frage,
wer ...
... den Kinderspielplatz baut.
Es ist doch nicht Aufgabe
des Kantons, den zu bauen.
Ich möchte eine kurze Antwort geben:
Wenn man dieses Projekt
nicht realisieren würde,
wird das
aus eigenen Mitteln des Kantons,
also von den Bürgern getragen.
Dementsprechend würde nachher die
ganze Fläche zur Verfügung stehen.
Aber was gibt es bei diesem Projekt,
das der Urner nicht benutzen kann?
In erster Linie
ist das Projekt nicht für den Urner,
rein von den Preisen her.
Es wurde auch schon erwähnt,
dass solche Projekte -
wie man in Andermatt sieht -
die Immobilienpreise erhöhen.
Ob das wirklich zum Vorteil
des Durchschnittsurners ist,
bleibe infrage gestellt.
Nicht alle Urner sind Grossver-
diener, die sich das leisten können.
Ich komme mir vor,
wie in einer Werbeveranstaltung
für dieses Projekt.
Ich bin enttäuscht vom Kanton
und von unseren Politikern.
Ich möchte auch etwas sagen:
Ich bin Joseph Schuler,
ich bin im Gemeinderat Isenthal.
Ich möchte
einen kleinen Werbespot machen.
Wir - das ist auch
die Haltung des Gemeinderats -
wären doch sehr froh, wenn wir heute
Abend einen Prozess beginnen können.
Dass nicht alle
einfach den Löffel ver...
Es ist sicher wunderschön,
an der Isleten zu leben.
Aber es ist trotzdem
eine Industriebrache.
Wir müssen wirklich etwas machen.
Ich mache nichts,
was ihr nicht wollt.
Da bleibe ich lieber zu Hause -
oder in Andermatt.
Das reicht auch.
Prost.
Mir gefällt das Projekt übrigens.
- Hm?
Mir gefällt das Projekt.
- Super.
Nach der Präsentation
und der Fragerunde
lädt der ägyptische Investor
zu Bier und Schinkengipfeli.
Ob er mit so viel Misstrauen
gerechnet hat?
Bevor er sich unters Volk mischt,
wiederholt er
vor den Medien mehrfach,
wie klein das Projekt an der Isleten
werden wird.
(Französisch)
Herr Sawiris, darf ich etwas fragen?
Das sind alles Medienleute.
Eigentlich möchte die Bevölkerung
einen Kontakt zu Ihnen.- Ja.
Ich finde es nicht fair,
dass Sie ...
Die schreiben ihre Geschichten ...
- Sowieso, ja.
Es reicht auch.
- Sie haben ihre Geschichte.
Ich habe lange gewartet.
- Ja, ja.
Ich bin lieber so.
- Wunderbar.
Sie sind auch wunderbar.
Sie haben mich gerettet.
- Ja.
Ich hätte den Mut nicht,
das allein zu machen.
Gekonnt und charmant entschärft
der Geschäftsmann die Situation.
Was wirst du Eveline rapportieren?
Ich habe ihr schon rapportiert.
Es hat mich erstaunt, dass ziemlich
viele kritische Stimmen kamen.
Das finde ich natürlich gut.
Disneyland.
Es hiess - von Sawiris Seite her -,
sie hätten eine Webseite.
Dort könne man sich melden
und dass die besten Ideen
ja immer aus der Bevölkerung kämen.
Was ist das Fazit
der Präsidentin der Grünen Uri?
Ja, dass es
sicher noch nicht vorbei sei.
Dass wir weiter ...
... für unsere Vorstellungen
kämpfen werden.
Tschau.
So.
Sehen wir uns das Ganze an, oder?
- Ja.
Ich treffe Eveline Lüönd an dem Ort,
wo ägyptische Grossbauideen auf Urner
Naturschutzvorstellungen prallen.
Bisher hat es die Grünen-Präsidentin
nicht geschafft,
mit Samih Sawiris
persönlich in Kontakt zu treten.
Mehrere Versuche sind gescheitert.
Auch heute
hat der Geschäftsmann keine Zeit.
Lüönd steht dem ganzen Vorhaben -
auch ein halbes Jahr
nach der Präsentation -
noch immer skeptisch gegenüber.
Es würde sicher belebter werden.
- Ja.
Das ist genau das,
was der Kanton will.
Ja. Aber es  i s t  sehr belebt.
- Tourismusförderung.
Es ist sehr belebt, aber ...
... der Tourismus
bringt nicht gleich viel Geld ...
... wie der andere Tourismus.
Und das stört dich:
Dass es hauptsächlich ums Geld geht?
Mich stören Aussagen wie:
"Jeder Quadratmeter
muss gewinnbringend genutzt werden."
Es stört mich,
dass es mehr Verkehr produziert -
auf dem See und der Strasse.
Es stört uns.
Das sind so diese Sachen.
Ich habe nichts gegen Tourismus,
aber wir haben im Kanton Uri ...
Vor Andermatt-Zeiten ...
Und auch an vielen anderen Orten ...
Das ist eher nachhaltiger Tourismus,
der gemacht wird.
Oder etwas verschlafen.
Die Frage ist: Was will man?
- Ja.
Die Zeiten ändern sich ja.
Alles zu konservieren, wie es war,
kann es ja auch nicht sein.
Nein.
Aber alles auszubluten,
kann es auch nicht sein.
Da passiert ein bisschen was.
Warst du schon auf dem Areal?
Ich habe es
erst von aussen und oben gesehen.
Ja, es ist ein altes Fabrikgelände.
- Ja, ja.
Weisst du, ich ...
... würde nie bestreiten, dass
das Potenzial für Veränderung hat.
Aber unsere Vorstellung ...
Ich spaziere hier mit der Vision
eines Freizeit-/Erholungsparks rum.
Einfach begrünt.
Ein Industrielehrpfad,
auf dem man die Geschichte sieht.
Dass es Gastronomie hat,
den Verhältnissen angepasst.
Ich habe die Projektskizze dabei ...
Mhm.
- ... die sie ...
... präsentiert haben.
Wo wir stehen, ist etwa ...
... hier. Irgendwo hier.
- Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist die Welt.
Deine Idee ist ein bisschen klein,
sage ich jetzt mal.
Kanton Uri halt.
Du sprichst
von einem Naturlehrpfad ...- Nein.
Industrielehrpfad.
- Industrielehrpfad.
Und davon,
den Obstbaumbestand zu sichern ...
Mhm.
- Das klingt alles ...
... etwas von Hand gestrickt im
Vergleich zu dem, was hier passiert.
Mhm.
Passt das in die heutige Zeit?
"Von Hand gestrickt",
weil ich kein Bild zeigen kann?
Nein.
Es klingt halt ein bisschen
nach Bewahren, so wie es früher war.
Sehr rückwärtsschauend.
Und das ist gross.
Das ist Glamour. Das ist Welt.
Mhm. Das ist heute?
- Ja.
Findest du?
- Ich weiss es nicht. Ich frage dich.
Ich finde, "heute" ist auch anders.
Ich finde, dass solche
Retortenresorts "gestern" sind.
Wir sind in unserer heutigen Zeit.
Wir sind konfrontiert
mit Themen der Klimaerwärmung ...
... von
zurückgehender Biodiversität ...
Ich finde, dass das out of der Zeit
ist, in der wir heute leben.
Ich finde nicht,
dass es ums Bewahren geht.
Man muss auch realisieren -
auch auf den Kanton Uri bezogen -,
was die Urner Werte sind.
Das sind sie für mich nicht.
Das ist Glamour.
Aber der ...
Den hat man an anderen Orten
in der Schweiz.
Ich finde, das ist ...
An dieser Idee ist für mich nichts
revolutionär, innovativ oder neu.
Für mich ist das in Bezug
auf dieses Seeufer deplatziert.
Es wurde nicht geschaut,
was hier ist ...
... und was hier reinpassen würde.
Es gibt Bevölkerungsteile,
die das sicher toll finden,
herzukommen, etwas einzukaufen, sich
zu setzen und ein Cüpli zu trinken.
Mit der Jacht bzw. dem Boot
hin- und wieder wegzufahren ...
Ich glaube schon,
dass es den Bevölkerungsteil gibt.
Aber ein nicht kleiner Teil
der Bevölkerung
würde einen Campingplatz
mit Feuerstelle, eine Liegewiese ...
... vielleicht einen Industrie-
lehrpfad und sicher ein Restaurant
auch schön finden.
Wenn du dich so umschaust ...
- Mhm.
... und Herr Sawiris um die Kurve
käme: Was würdest du ihm sagen?
Machen Sie einen schönen ...
... Freizeit-Natur-
Naherholungsflecken ...
... für die Urner Bevölkerung.
Schaffen Sie etwas,
das noch nicht hier war,
mit dem man sich
wirklich neu profilieren kann.
Auch in Ihrem Metier.
Gerne hätte auch ich
mit Samih Sawiris
über die Ideen der Grünen-Präsidentin
des Kantons Uri gesprochen.
Aber auch für mich hat er keine Zeit.
Schriftlich lässt er ausrichten,
er sei für realistische Ideen
immer offen,
von der Grünen Partei seien jedoch
keine konkreten Ideen eingegangen.
Die komplette Ablehnung des Projekts
stehe für sie im Fokus.
Die Gegnerinnen und Gegner kümmerten
sich weder um Eigentum noch Kosten.
Zudem sagt Sawiris, dass er den Punkt
des Verkehrs sehr ernst nehme.
Es brauche dafür die Zusammenarbeit
mit Gemeinden und ein Gesamtkonzept.
Juni 2022.
Zwei Monate nach der Bürger-
information über die Marina-Idee.
Sessionstag des Kantonsparlaments,
des Landrats.
Meine ehemalige Schulkollegin
ist seit drei Jahren Urner Landrätin.
Als wir vor 30 Jahren
in der Oberstufe waren,
hätte ich nie erwartet,
dass du plötzlich im Landrat,
im Parlament des Kanton Uri sitzt.
Du warst die Revoluzzerin.
Und jetzt bist du im Parlament.
- Ja.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Ja. Aber ...
Das Revoluzzerinnenherz
habe ich immer noch.
Irgendwann
ist einfach die Konsequenz davon,
dass gewisse Dinge
für einen nicht stimmen,
dass man sich selbst einbringt
und schaut, wie das ist.
Was mich auch auszeichnet:
Ich mag neue Erfahrungen
und Abenteuer
und lasse mich gerne auf etwas ein.
Es ist auch nicht alles
ein Engagement für ewig.
Darum: rein, voll rein.
All in. Genau.
Im Urner Rathaus war Eveline Lüönd
vom ersten Tag an eine Exotin -
gerade mal zwei Grüne gibt es im
64-köpfigen Urner Kantonsparlament.
Der Stachel im Fleisch zu sein,
sei sie sich gewohnt, sagt mir Lüönd.
Doch:
Man kennt sich im kleinen Kanton.
Jemandem auf die Füsse zu treten,
ist schwierig.
Der zuständige Regierungsrat weiss:
Heute kommt sie wieder
mit ihrer Marina-Opposition.
Frau Präsidentin, Herren Regierungs-
räte, meine Damen und Herren:
Am 31. März dieses Jahres
und am 2. Mai dieses Jahres
haben die Grüne Partei Uri
und das Flüeler Komitee
rund 10'000 Unterschriften
gegen die Projektidee
"Marinas am Urnersee" eingereicht.
Das ist plus/minus zwei Monate her.
Aktuell steht die Projektidee
an der Isleten noch in Diskussion.
Bis heute fehlt eine offizielle
Reaktion der Regierung,
die direkt mit der Botschaft aus
der Bevölkerung adressiert wurde.
Meine Frage: Wann und in welcher
Form gedenkt die Regierung
auf dieses starke Votum aus
der Urner Bevölkerung zu reagieren?
Frau Präsidentin,
meine Damen und Herren:
Der Regierungsrat hat die beiden
Petitionen zur Kenntnis genommen
und auch die damit verbundenen
Ängste und Bedenken.
Die Petition - damit komme ich
konkret auf Ihre Frage zu sprechen -
als politisches Instrument,
stellt keinen
förmlich zu behandelnden Antrag dar.
Die Behörden müssen das lediglich
zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Der Urner Regierungsrat
geht in der Regel aber weiter.
Das ist auch in diesem Fall
so vorgesehen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass der Regierungsrat anfangs Juli
seine Haltung dazu kundtun wird.
Sag mal, Eveline:
Die Frage wurde mehr oder weniger
detailliert beantwortet.
Ja. Ich bin ...
Ich bin gespannt,
was dabei rauskommt.
Ich habe gewisse Ideen
bzw. Vermutungen.
Die da wären?
- Dass man irgendwie sagt ...
Dass man sich drauf stützt,
dass es Prozesse gebe ...
Die Gemeinde kann mit der
Zonenplanung Einfluss nehmen
und über den kantonalen Richtplan
kann man ...
Ich finde,
das ist einfach extrem hochschwellig
für die Normalbürger,
die das beschäftigt.
Gut.
Da muss schon noch
ein bisschen was passieren, oder?
Das ist so. Ja, ja.
- Okay.
Wir müssen aber die Grundlagen
haben, bevor wir es beurteilen.
Daran muss der Investor
jetzt arbeiten.- Klar. Okay.
Gut. Danke. Guten Appetit.
- Bitte. Dir auch.
Herr Furrer, darf ich kurz?
Landrätin Lüönd ist skeptisch
gegenüber der Urner Regierung,
die das Projekt
von Anfang an unterstützt hat.
Der Eindruck ist falsch.
Wir sind durchaus kritisch.
Aber unser Auftrag
bildet sich im Richtplan ab.
Das öffentliche Interesse
gibt uns einen Auftrag.
Es besagt, dass wir die Urner
Seeregion touristisch entwickeln.
Das ist im Grundsatz
ein privater Investor,
der Möglichkeiten
und auch den Willen hat,
ein touristisches Projekt
zu entwickeln.
Heute ist ein freudiger Tag.
Für einmal keine Politik.
Eveline Lüönds Mutter
feiert ihren 67. Geburtstag.
Grüezi, Agnes.
Ja, hoi, Eveline.
Eveline.
- Hoi.
Schön. Danke vielmals
für die Gratulation.- Bitte.
Die Familie
trifft sich in einem Restaurant
im Industriegebiet von Schattdorf.
Die ganze Familie ist hier:
neben Mama Agnes
Lebenspartner Björn,
die beiden Schwestern mit Ehemännern,
Patenkind und Nichte.
Evelines Vater
ist vor einigen Jahren gestorben.
Wir kriegen etwas, Mami?
Aber du hast Geburtstag.
Ein Tischkärtchen muss sein.
- Okay.
Schön, dass ihr alle hier seid.
Das freut mich.
Prost, Corinne. Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl, Mami.
Auf dich.
Wir sind sehr ähnlich
und doch sehr verschieden.
Wir haben denselben harten Schädel.
Ja.
Und wir tun unsere Meinung
auch so kund.
Eveline sagte, sie sei
in einem Matriarchat aufgewachsen.
Mit einer starken Mutter.
- Ja. Ja. Das brauchte es auch.
Ich hatte
einen dementsprechenden Mann,
der mich das ausleben liess.
Er liess mich machen.
Dass Eveline
in die Politik eingestiegen ist
und auch oft
auf die Hinterbeine steht ...
Sie ist auch in einer Partei, die ...
Sie hätte einen einfacheren Weg
wählen können.
Erstaunt dich das?
Schlussendlich nicht.
Ich hatte anfangs
verdammt grosse Angst.
Als sie gewählt wurde,
war ja gerade diese Zeit,
als man die Politiker so mobbte.
Da hatte ich ziemlich lange Angst
und fragte mich,
ob sie das durchsteht.
Ist da ein gewisser Stolz?
- Sehr.
Sehr. Ich bin
auf alle drei Kinder sehr stolz.
Zurück im Politalltag:
Die Grüne Partei Uri
lanciert eine Volksinitiative gegen
das Sawiris-Projekt an der Isleten.
Die Petition vor einem Jahr hat
nicht die gewünschte Wirkung erzielt.
Der Grossinvestor
und die Urner Regierung
halten an den Marina-Plänen
wie gehabt fest.
Grüezi.
Ich sammle Unterschriften für
die Initiative "Isleten für alle".
Grüezi. Darf ich fragen:
Ich sammle Unterschriften ...
Anstatt Hotel und Jachthafen
von Samih Sawiris
will Eveline Lüönd Natur.
Zur heutigen touristischen Nutzung
an der Isleten sagt sie Ja,
was darüber hinausgeht, lehnt sie ab.
Also ein Verbot
der Idee von Samih Sawiris.
Ja, praktisch so.
Das kann man so sagen.
Genau.
- Du lächelst.
Ja, ich lächle.
Weil ich es gut ...
Also, ich finde es richtig.
Man muss Position beziehen.
- Hat Samih Sawiris reagiert?
Auf die Initiative? Nein.
Da gab es keine Reaktion.
Ich nehme die Strategie der Isen AG
so wahr:
"Wir beachten sie einfach nicht,
dann kriegen sie kein Gewicht."
So.
Jetzt, im Mai 2023, haben die Grünen
genügend Unterschriften beisammen.
Das Urner Stimmvolk wird entscheiden.
Sagen die Bürger und Bürgerinnen Ja
zu den Plänen der Grünen Uri,
ist das Marina-Projekt
von Samih Sawiris vom Tisch.
Nach Lancierung der Volksinitiative
hat Samih Sawiris
endlich Zeit für Eveline Lüönd.
Doch das Treffen
bringt keine Einigung.
Die Vorstellungen,
was an der Isleten geschehen soll,
liegen noch immer weit auseinander,
sagen mir die beiden Parteien.
Der ägyptische Investor
hält an seinem "normalen
und nicht Luxusprojekt" fest.
Wie wäre es
mit Samih Sawiris am Seil?
Ja ...
Das wäre sehr spannend.
Er könnte mir vertrauen.
Und du ihm?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Das müsste ich zuerst testen.
Das wäre eine spannende Erfahrung
für Samih Sawiris:
zu klettern und jemand anderem
vertrauen zu müssen.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023